straight ahead
all on crime daily could an admitted
rapist also be a serial killer
our exclusive interview with one of his
survivors and the detective who says
there's more to the case he truly is a
predator
an animal pursuing things that are
really really bad
more arrests for the siege on the
nation's capitol how an officers quit
thinking
likely save lives
plus should a woman be executed for
killing a mother to steal her baby
her defense says she's mentally ill and
a legal loss for the so-called doomsday
cult couple
why attorneys for lori valo and chad
dabal are crying foul play
red flags are raised eyebrows are raised
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin
detectives in kentucky now believe a man
behind a cold rape case
is not only a serial rapist but possibly
a serial killer too
antoinette levy spoke exclusively with a
woman who survived a brutal attack
42 years ago yeah brian michael dean
tate is actually 78 years old and he has
accepted a plea deal that will send him
to prison for 12 years
detectives in boone county kentucky say
that tate confessed to them that he had
raped
several young girls and the woman who
survived that attack back in 1978 said
that tate had told her
that he actually killed several of the
girls
how hard has this been just living with
this for so many years
it ruined my life it changed every
aspect of my life
i i was just never the same always
afraid
that somebody was going to kidnap me
again like he did
he is michael dean tate the survivor
couldn't put a name with the face of the
man who attacked her for more than 40
years
it was october 1st 1978 in park hills
kentucky
when the petite 22 year old ballet
dancer pulled into her garage
and was grabbed from behind she was
taken a couple of blocks away
raped and tortured for hours in tate's
car
i will say it was very violent and
there wasn't anything he didn't do you
know it was just my reaction to all
of it that saved me and uh my
non-reaction
that saved me surprisingly tate let her
go
but not before making an admission he
told me i was the only one he let go
he gave me the number 13 in 1978
and i know he didn't stop then so that
was the number of the girls he told me
he killed
she's an amazing person and what she did
to survive is just
kind of crazy the survivor's case went
cold
until boone county sheriff's detective
coy cox looked into it in
cox and his cold case detective partner
were looking at a murder and rape case
around that same time that had
similarities cox won't comment on which
case
but the sheriff's website lists the
murder of carol sue kleber in june of
1976 as a cold case
an old news story says claber was seen
getting into a car with a young man that
day
taking her bicycle out of the trunk of
his car claber had been raped and beaten
to death
so cox decided to look into similar
cases
including the survivors she told the
detectives the police officers early on
that he grabbed the door right there
so turns out that fingerprint
when they first submitted it to the fbi
there was no match
in the database so we submitted it and
that's when we got this information back
on
michael d tate that this fingerprint
belongs to
michael d tate cox and his partner went
to georgia to interview tate who had a
history of not talking to police
i can't remember my exact words but i
said do you want to talk about it
and uh and he said
i hurt a lot of women i raped a lot of
women
because i just want to tell them i'm
sorry cox says tate preferred girls
between 14 and 16 and
even younger and confessed over four
hours to multiple rapes in many states
his job enabling him to travel the
country but when it came to discussing
murders
cox said tate clammed up a lot of things
that his body did
when we asked certain questions it's
like we need to keep working harder
because
he has done a lot more serious crimes
cox says tate was caught in the act of
raping a girl in chicago years ago
and tried to lure two girls in oak park
illinois
he was arrested for gross sexual
imposition in cincinnati in 1974
that case later dismissed the
investigation
is far from over and the survivor is
grateful
the gods of the cold cases
i feel like i owe my life to them
because now i can spend the rest of my
life a lot happier
all i want is him to admit to what he
did
that rape survivor her father was
actually
a police officer who was killed in the
line of duty before she was even born so
she had never even met him
and she said that somehow you know she
believes in the spiritual aspect of this
that somehow he could have had a hand
in helping solve this and he that he's
been with her throughout this
i actually reached out to michael tate's
lawyer twice
for a comment i have not yet heard back
tate will be formally sentenced to that
12 years in prison
later this week brian no this is the one
part i'm kind of confused about
how was tate not locked up if he'd been
caught committing other sex crimes in
the past
you know that's a very good question and
detective cox you know addressed that
with me when we did this interview he
said that sexual assault was simply
treated
sadly much differently back in the 70s
and early 80s
the penalties weren't quite as harsh and
sometimes
the victims were dismissed so that is
part of the reason and also he just
wasn't
caught for crimes that maybe were a
little more serious on the scale of
sexual assault
gotcha joining us for a closer look at
this case is veteran swap member and law
and crime analyst lisa lockwood
along with angenette levy and terry
austin lisa talk to us about what it's
going to take to match tate's
confessions
with the multiple cases in multiple
states
well the fbi right now is trying to pin
him
on other cases because of the
information that they have from this
victim
who now we are getting justice for after
42 years
the fact that there was a fingerprint it
was a cold case what we need to do
the fbi is certainly doing is looking at
the other places that he lived he was in
ohio he was in
kentucky he was in illinois he was in
tennessee
so all of these regions they need to try
and find out what his address was
looking at driver's license registration
information where he filed taxes where
he lived
and start opening up cold cases of jane
does in those areas to try and find out
did we have jane does who were raped
were they brutally raped did they fit
the same profile
as the victim who came forward in this
particular case
gotcha now terry tate is 78 and has some
health issues how hopeful are you
that these other cases can be solved
while he's still alive to assist
authorities
you know brian you make an excellent
point the key here is for authorities to
move very swiftly he
is of older age and you know he stated
that he was guilty and he's willing to
disclose
information about these other crimes
these other rapes
so the sooner the conversations take
place the better it's going to be hard
though because we know they're different
locations and so
it might be difficult to coordinate yeah
it's going to be difficult to coordinate
but we'll see how it plays out thank you
all for contributing
as as we look back in this case we'll
obviously update you
still ahead on law and crime daily the
officer of being called a hero during
the capital insurrection
and later why the woman charged with
falsely accusing a teen of stealing her
phone
is out of jail those cases and more
after the break
it's like a vlog
a capitol police officer is being hailed
as a hero for his bravery during the
attempted insurrection
officials say officer eugene goodman
tricked a group of protesters
and riders into following him away from
the senate chamber
to a hallway where more officers were
waiting
more than 120 people have been arrested
in connection to the chaos at the
capitol
among them an iowa man identified as a
leader in the group of people seen
walking up the stairs and confronting
officer goodman
take a close look at the entire
interaction
government
federal investigators say the man seen
here in the cap leading the crowd
has been identified as doug jensen he
was arrested at his home
near des moines iowa he's facing five
federal charges including trespassing
and disorderly conduct back with me is
crime analyst lisa lockwood
and terry austin lisa your record speaks
for itself in terms of law enforcement
and as a veteran
um you've been doing this for some time
if you could speak with officer eugene
goodman about his actions that day
what would you say to him first of all
how honorable his quick action
everything was on par in all of the
training that police officers receive
regarding crowd control and that that
training has increased
during all of the riots that we've been
enduring uh since the pandemic
between antifa and blm and right wing
fanatics
so what he did is he went into the
direction where he knew
other officers were there to offer
assistance
he went a different direction than the
actual chamber and got them away from
the um penetration of congress where we
know that they had not
exited that area of safety so
completely commendable he thought on his
feet he didn't panic and he still
maintained his radial contact
throughout the entire situation so
extremely commendable
and um he didn't he didn't allow them to
ruffle him up he was professional
and a job well done exactly now terry
with arrest numbers exceeding 100
is there any of the cases that you're
looking at and you're just thinking
you've got to be kidding me you know the
one case that stands out to me brian is
the arrest of richard barnett he's from
arkansas he was the man sitting at
speaker pelosi's desk
he had his feet up on the desk and he
actually took an envelope
he said that he would you know leave a
quarter to pay for the envelope
but he was eventually taken into custody
early friday and he's currently being
charged with
knowingly entering and restricted
building
violent entry and disorderly conduct and
theft of public property
let me tell you a quarter is not going
to do the trick he's going to have to
pay
a lot more than that for the crime that
he committed i mean he was
way too bold as far as i'm concerned and
uh he was actually interviewed and he
had no remorse
for what he had done so well done
getting this arrest
yeah a quarter is not much of a defense
there in that case the one for me was
adam johnson who was seen taking the
lectern
the first thing i thought to myself was
this guy definitely going to want to
take the stand and testify
and that's probably not going to be the
best route in that case
and in other top legal news the woman
dubbed soho karen is out of jail
unsupervised release
maya poncetto is facing charges of
attempted robbery
grand larceny attempted assault and an
acting in a manner interest to a child
police say she falsely accused the black
teenager of stealing her cell phone
the teen's father grammy award winner
kenyon harold senior
filmed the incident on his cell phone
prosecutors say ponzero is a suspect in
another nyc case
and is charged in three other incidents
in 2020 including dui and driving with a
suspended license
coming up on law and crime daily should
authorities execute the only female on
u.s death row
plus a couple accused of covering up the
deaths of two children
will not have a new prosecutor a ruling
in the lorry valo day bell case you
don't want to miss
lawyers for a woman set to be executed
this week for cutting a baby from her
mother's womb
say that her life should be spared lisa
montgomery was convicted of using a
kitchen knife to cut
an eight-month-old fetus out of a
woman's womb to try to raise her as her
own
bobby joe stinnett was found in a pool
of her own blood the baby survived and
was returned to her father
montgomery's lawyers say she suffers
from mental illness
brought on by childhood abuse her
execution is scheduled for january 12th
she was raped by her stepfather when she
was
just a preteen she was
sex trafficked by her mother she
is someone who was gang-raped she was
gang-raped
and then urinated on by her rapists
when she was still a child this is a
woman who went through
unimaginable violence
returning for analysis is lisa lockwood
and terry austin lisa thoughts and
reactions as we hear
that the first woman in 70 years is
scheduled for an execution
yeah incredible i mean it's a horrific
case and
it was scheduled this was her sentence
we knew that the death penalty was
coming
so this is a last-ditch effort to prove
that she's not competent the only
issue i i believe with that is she was
competent for trial
so since this happened in 2004 her
mental health has declined
so i don't know how successful they're
going to be with trying to get a stay
for
for this execution and terry that's the
million dollar question we've seen a lot
of pushes
over the last couple of months if not
years for these kind of pardons
with the clock ticking do you see any
potential last-ditch efforts that could
save her life
i don't at this point i think the time
might have expired for montgomery and i
agree with lisa the fact that she was
competent at the time of trial it might
be difficult to say
she's not competent now so you know she
has this effort that she might be able
to convince donald trump he has the
power to grant clemency
but i think at this point because of
everything that's going on with covet 19
and everything that's going on as far as
the
riots in dc are concerned she's not
going to be able to
get his attention and i think the hope
of any sort of leniency at this point
is sort of diminished i guess the
question is terry
let's say that all that chaos that we're
talking about that everyone's going
through right now wasn't there
covid capitol hill new president if
those were gone do you think she'd have
a good chance
at clemency if all those were out the
window she'd definitely have a better
chance brian
i don't think i'd categorize it as good
i think because
she was already found competent that
point is going to hurt her
yeah i agree there i don't think it's
going to help her out regardless of the
background in in
today's country uh when we come back a
judge's ruling in the case of the
so-called doomsday cult couple
the legal blow to the defense of lori
valo and chad davao
next
the prosecutor of the so-called doomsday
cult couple will not be removed from the
case
for now lori valo and her husband chad
dabel are facing charges of conspiracy
to conceal
and destruction of evidence in the
deaths of valo's two children
the bodies of j.j vallo and tyler ryan
were discovered
buried in a shallow grave on chad
dabal's idaho property
they're not being charged with murder
but the prosecutor was heard on a secret
recording
with a meeting of valo's sister saying
he plans to file conspiracy to commit
murder charges
their defense says that the recording
should disqualify the prosecutor
i think it becomes quite a bit more
disgusting when you hear the tone
and the phrases and the speed of the the
language and the and the words
used um when we look at here in a
summary you have
mr wood admitting on this recording that
he was in hawaii at the time that mr
that mrs valo was mrs dabel excuse me
was arrested
he was in arizona at the time that these
statements from these witnesses were
taken
i still have yet to try to figure out
why he's present at any of this
an attorney for prosecutor rob wood says
he did nothing wrong by speaking with a
potential witness
in the case miss shiflett is not
mr david she is not miss valo she's a
potential witness in the case
and there's no evidence to present that
mr wood directed her to say anything
other than tell the truth courts have
said the
appropriate remedy for this is to
cross-examine or there's
alternatives exclude the witnesses
those types of things so your honor
based on this based on the law
in the state of idaho based on the law
in the supreme court of the united
states
and what we have presented to you there
is not a way to disqualify
the prosecutor mr wood from this case
after hearing both sides the judge ruled
in the prosecution's favor
without knowing whether or not this
potential witness will ever be called to
testify at a trial the court
cannot find at this time that the
interaction between mr wood and the
witness
would render mr wood's continued
participation in this case
unfair and cannot determine that the
prosecutor's pre-trial activity will be
a material
issue in this case for those reasons
then the motions to disqualify
mr wood are denied
now if ms shiflett in the future is
called to testify
at trial in this case the court would
require
a pre-trial hearing based on the
evidence i heard at this hearing
lisa you've interviewed witnesses and
victims did you see anything wrong in
this interview
by rob wood i didn't what the goal is
is to make people as comfortable as
possible in order for them to
divulge information and have a symbiotic
relationship
so their assertion was that there was
intimidation there was coercing there
was
coaching there was influencing they
weren't able to prove any of that
one of the things they also said is that
the death penalty was brought up and
this this probably scared her
but she summer was the one who brought
up the death penalty
and said is it possible that she could
be charged with that
and he divulged the information he put
his cards on the table and said yeah it
is a possibility he doesn't want to go
there
if that's the case so the information
that he received i believe there was a
lot of of laughing during the interview
which is great because it made her feel
comfortable
and made her feel at ease so i think
they made the right decision in this
yeah and i think at the bottom line they
also didn't actually speak to summer
shiplet to see if this actually did
affect
what she was saying terry you called it
the prosecutor is going to stay
what do you think the next moves are for
the defense
you know i'm glad he's going to stay
he's a good prosecutor
but i think the defense is going to
continue to make
motion after motion to whittle the case
down i
anticipate they're going to make motions
to exclude evidence they're going to
make motions to exclude
witnesses and i think the judge is going
to
continue to look at the case as a whole
and
hopefully you know on this motion the
judge actually
said that there was you know basically
no harm no file and he did say
that one of the remedies would be a
pre-trial
taint hearing to determine whether or
not her testimony
was actually influenced by rob woods and
i think
if in fact summer is called as a witness
they could easily remedy the situation
by asking her if she was influenced
and frankly i think she will say no this
is how i felt
yeah you're definitely going to see
another potential pre-trial hearing here
lisa terry thank you for joining us and
thank you for joining us here at long
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
you